today we're talking about new Cloud
regions the new security voices blog
autonomic data security and a new log
query Library I'm Sarah and welcome to
this week in Cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news
to meet growing demand for cloud
services in Asia Pacific we're excited
to announce our plans to bring three new
Google Cloud regions to Malaysia
Thailand and New Zealand
these new Cloud regions represent our
ongoing commitment to support digital
transformation across Asia Pacific we're
excited to announce a new blog called
security voices this new living blog is
authored by a diverse group of people
across multiple security teams at Google
that conceive craft build test explain
and bring to market the wide range of
security products and services that our
customers use today
diversity equity and inclusion are
important for their own sake they also
make for better business sense
stay up to date with security voices on
the cloud blog and Linkedin ninety
percent of all data today was created in
the last two years that's 2.5
quintillion bytes of data per day
as data usage has undergone drastic
expansion and changes in the past five
years so have your business needs for
data
autonomic data security is security
that's been integrated with data
throughout its life cycle it can make
things easier on users by freeing them
from defining and redefining Myriad
rules about who can do what when and
where
it's an approach that keeps Pace with
constantly evolving cyber threats and
business changes whether you're
troubleshooting an issue or analyzing
your logs finding the right logs quickly
is critical that's why we recently
launched a query library and other new
features to make querying your logs even
easier with text search and drop down
features that are designed to make
querying something possible with just a
few clicks
check the blog for more details if you
want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud